so as you can see we have a we've
improved our logo from this very fancy
hand-drawn logo to this logo I'm not
entirely sure how it was made but I
understand it cost about five dollars so
very very fancy incredibly fancy so I'm
talking about sparkling pandas how many
people just out of curiosity you know
what spark is okay pretty good how many
people know what pandas is awesome cool
okay great it looks like my assumptions
were pretty much straight on so I'm
really happy I'd like to throw a special
shout out to Juliet
Hoagland for her amazing work some of
the slides are from when we gave this
talk together a while back and she also
got our test suite passing again last
night at 1:00 a.m. all of the tests pass
so I think I'm really stoked about that
and and so thanks to Juliet she's not
here today but you know super happy fun
times so my name is Holden my preferred
pronouns are she or her I'm a co-author
of the learning spark book there's
actually going to be a book signing
right after this at the O'Reilly thing
and I think there's 25 free copies is
what they told me so if you're
interested in learning more about spark
you know you can come and do that and we
can chat about spark I'm an engineer at
Alpine data labs I've been at a bunch of
places before that always sort of doing
big data II machine learning or sort of
recommendation type problems
once upon a time way way back when I was
a PM intern at Microsoft and that did
not go well but you know it's good now
I'm back as an engineer and things well
I mean I'm at all fine as an engineer
anyways being an engineer much better
fit for me you can find me on Twitter
Holden Caro if you don't have enough cat
pictures in your life or complaints
about American healthcare follow me on
Twitter you know you can watch a
Canadian try and understand what's going
on down here the slides from today's
talk and the workshop that I gave
yesterday are both going to be on my
SlideShare so
if you do want to take picture of one
slide this is probably the slide to take
a picture of so you can find the rest of
the slides later on if you're all like
professional and stuff when you don't
like cat pictures or like you just want
to talk to me about more than cat
pictures you can be on LinkedIn for
business business numbers like let me
know like you were in my talk because
there's there's a lot of you and I won't
recognize your face but you know add me
on LinkedIn if you want to talk
professional so it seems like almost
everyone knows what pandas is so we're
just gonna go super fast today we're
focusing on pandas dataframes
and they're through these really awesome
tabular data structures and they make it
really easy to slice and dice data if
you don't know what pandas is check out
pandas data org and and pandas is the
next best thing since sliced bread I
think it's awesome I also think SPARC is
awesome and I wanted to put these two
awesome things together so even though
most people know what SPARC is just for
the few people that don't it's this
really awesome distributed computing
system that's a lot faster than
MapReduce which is maybe not the highest
bar to jump over in the world but it's
pretty important because that's sort of
the pre-existing standard it also has a
really really nice API compared to
MapReduce where you only really have
these two types of operations we get a
much richer set of operations we can do
so SPARC is is sort of split up into all
of these different pieces although it
does ship together as a unit today we're
going to be focusing on sort of core
Apache spark and also spark sequel and
the data frame component that ships with
spark called spark data frames there are
things like streaming graph tools
although I haven't used the graph tools
but essentially there's all of the sort
of distributed computing type things
that you would normally do with separate
projects together in a single project
which makes it a lot easier to integrate
the tools together and I think that's
pretty cool because I don't like
maintaining multiple services if I can
put it all together I'm happy and SPARC
makes it pretty easy there's also some
benefits from this from sort of a
development point of view
in terms of core apache spark gets a lot
of improvements happening to it because
like streaming needed faster tasks
launching and then this faster task
launching improves the sequel queries as
well so like there's this cross benefit
thing with having this common platform
so we're gonna be talking about doing
some stuff on top of spark so I'm gonna
have to use some spark specific terms or
I'm going to maybe don't have to but I
want to there's the spark context and
the spark context is sort of like our
window into the world of spark we can
think of it as just like a connection to
our cluster it's a bit more than that
but it's it's where we're gonna ask
spark to load data we could create
accumulators and things like that on the
spark context as well there's also the
sequel context and the sequel context is
built on top of the spark context and it
gives us this window into all of the
sequel and sort of structured data views
of spark a transformation is something
which takes one of sparks distributed
collections which are called rdd's or a
data frame and gives us back another RTD
or data frame transformations are lazily
evaluated and that just means that when
we do a transformation the work doesn't
happen right away it happens later once
we do this something that requires that
work so an example would be counting the
elements or or saving it and those
things are actions so you might be
wondering why you're in this talk if
spark already has data frames right you
know why not just use the spark data
frames and and sparks data frames are
really cool but I think the sort of
painful part about sparks data frames is
they're not what we've come to expect
from data frames right if we're coming
from pandas or are the data frame API
just really isn't that rich we can do
really simple filtering we can write
sequel queries against stuff and and if
we want to write a bunch of sequel
queries against our data frames that's
great but if we want to start to do sort
of more complex type operations that we
would do in pandas the API just isn't
there and I'm not saying that this is a
bad thing or they should have this
really broad
p.i it's just a design choice that
they've made and you know I clearly made
a different one they're both really fast
one of the things that I really feel is
missing and spark dataframes personally
is index support so there's no real
index data in spark data frames which is
kind of frustrating especially if you're
used to working with index data frames
and there's also no visualizations so
today we're gonna look at sort of adding
some indexes and adding a really kind of
hokey visualization but it'll give you
an idea of how to add more so this panda
inside of a panda image is actually
leftover from like the first version of
the talk but it was too cute for me to
take out and just a bit of history
sparkling pandas had a very early
version which we made where what we did
is we created these distributed
collections and inside of each partition
on a distributed collection we would
store a single panda's data frame and
then we would distribute our work on
these distributed collections and we had
stuff to support group by and and all of
that stuff that works pretty well in
terms of like it's pretty easy to
implement but it turns out to be kind of
slow for some very high spark specific
reasons and then spark data frames came
along and spark data frames made it
possible to do things much faster albeit
with a bit more work on our part and I
overcame my natural inclinations to not
do work and and we worked on making a
faster one so let's let's start looking
at what spark sequel gives us right this
is just regular spark sequel so this
thing is deceptively simple it's really
it's really awesome that we're able to
call JSON file on an arbitrary file and
actually get a structured view out of it
how many people work with JSON data here
okay how many of you have had trouble
with your JSON data not necessarily
conforming to what you thought the
schema was okay that's like I think at
least 80% of the people there so
this is pretty awesome right spark is
actually able to go take this JSON file
and do schema inference automatically
for us so to be honest like there are
times when I've just used spark sequel
just to figure out what the hell's going
on with my JSON data I pointed out like
a year's worth of like logs and run it
but anyways so you know we we can load
some data we can register it as a sequel
table and we can write queries against
it that's that's cool you know it's not
bad but you know maybe we want to do a
little more so you know maybe we want to
bring it back to a panda's data frame
afterwards so we import our pandas we we
do a similar thing we load some data
from HDFS we filter it down to something
that's small enough to fit on a single
machine and then we call to pandas on it
and this gives us back a local pandas
dataframe to work with what's really
cool is like this is actually just in
spark regular spark this isn't sparkling
pandas and I think to be honest for a
lot of people this is a pretty good fit
for you're gonna want to do like pretty
often we have these really really huge
data sets and we only care about this
tiny sliver and and spark sequel makes
it really easy to do that and bring it
back to a panda's data frame but
sometimes you know we need to do more
than just the simple filter before we
can bring it down to a single machine to
do sort of more complex analysis oh yeah
we can also take a local data frame and
make it distributed that's useful
mostly for joining data it's it's not if
your data fits on a single machine
anyways these probably don't bother
distributing it unless you need to do a
drawing but so we're gonna we're gonna
go beyond just this simple filter
mechanism and we're gonna combine our
really fast distributed system spark
with our really awesome happy API pandas
it's going to be like peanut butter and
jelly
as you can see the peanut butter and
jelly sandwich so you know we're gonna
try and add more functionalities data
frames the natural way to start doing
this is to look whereas Park wants you
to extend data frames there's a few
places
we can do this the simplest thing is we
can add UDF's who's written a hive UDF
okay only a few people nevermind then
writing sparks equal UDF's is actually
pretty simple and I'll show one in a
little bit user-defined aggregates and
sparks equal is actually kind of
frustrating to do the API is getting a
lot better though so that's that's the
thing we can do another option and this
is the option that appeals to my inner
laziness is we can use bits of panda's
code so we could actually write our
UDF's and have them call panda's code
for us and a third option is spark
packages there's this wonderful
community site of all sorts of spark
libraries you've got things like reading
in from CSV or Avro or stuff like that
on top of like different machine
learning algorithms and stuff so we can
we can extend sparks equal in that way
and that way is really awesome because
it's not all that much work right we
just install this extra package and we
get this additional functionality so how
do we make our peanut butter and jelly
sandwich that's really the question
we've got this this sparkling pandas API
and our goal for the sparkling pandas
API is to be as close to pandas
compatible as is reasonable given that
I'm lazy so our sparkling pandas API
needs to store some little extra bits of
internal state that just don't show up
in spark data frames but most of our
calls
it'll look at this internal state and
translate them into calls on spark data
frames we'll have to add some UDF's
because for example there's no built-in
median function computing the median is
kind of a useful thing so we'll add some
UD apps for some of the UDF's we'll just
write some Scala code I'm sorry
Python conference people but you know
we'll write some Scala code because
that's sort of where SPARC is mostly and
we can get a better performance by
extending in the JVM for other things
where it would be a lot of work to write
the Scala code we'll just go ahead and
call some panda stuff for other things
we'll take our data frames and we'll
convert them into sort of these are
of pandas dataframes and do our
operations that way it's a little slower
but you know the it makes it much easier
to implement certain types of operations
so some of the group by stuff is done
this way even though it's slow it was
just a lot faster to implement and we'll
fix it if people actually want to use it
a lot and that's how we make our peanut
butter and jelly sandwich so let's go
and start start making some of that
sandwich together the first thing that
we're gonna do is we're gonna add index
names to pandas dataframes I'm sorry
yeah spark dataframes it's it's actually
pretty simple we're just gonna have to
keep track of our index names and when
we bring the data back we can still use
this two pandas thing we just need to
update the index names and update the
index names just involves translating
the spark sorry the index names into
these spark columns and vice versa
so for example since we can have unnamed
index names we'll have these like
special reserved fields in the pen in
the spark data frame and when we bring
it back we'll do some like sketchy
conversion stuff behind the scenes it's
pretty simple we can also like start
adding UDF's this UDF you know is not
actually one of the UDF's and sparkling
pandas because string length is is
pretty simple but the other ones don't
really fit super nicely on the slide
because they're a bit more complex but
you can see how adding UDF's to spark
sequel is really simple right we give it
a function name we provide a function
and we specify our return type and and
this is where we start extending stuff
with Scala and and I'm sorry I actually
I'm very sorry because there's something
called evil sequel on there and in case
you can't guess evil sequel tools is not
an official part of spark evil sequel
tools is because we are doing things
with the internals of spark sequel to
try and do some of these extensions
sometimes developers don't like it when
you are doing that and you have to lie
about who you are so evil sequel tools
pretends to be in this
bark package and lets us get access to
these column expressions so we can write
our own things that are going to extend
it so it's pretty simple I mean the
actual kurtosis implementation like we
can call Apache math Commons and there's
a really good implementation there
calling it from the Python side is a
little bit funky but really the main
thing and you don't have to understand
this code too much if you don't want to
is that pice bark is implemented using
something called pi for j has anyone
used PI for J oh wow
okay well um so PI for J is a really
simple bridge between Python and the JVM
and it lets us send sort of like we tell
the JVM what we want it to do and then
it'll send us back some results and this
is pretty useful because it lets us do
these sorts of things where we're
calling JVM functions and so this just
you know makes a column that's actually
a JVM function under the hood so you
know we can in addition to just adding
UDF's we can write things that are going
to wrap the data frame so so far what
we've done mostly has involved extending
a data frame but at the end of the day
right we need to expose a different API
to the user there's no plot function on
spark data frame so what we do is we
have a class which is wrapping the spark
data frame and exposing the Python API
that's similar ish to to the pandas API
and so this is just a plot it's really
simple and I think there's actually a
lot of really cool opportunities to make
visualizations work well in sparkling
pandas this one's especially easy
because it's just a bar chart so a lot
of things we can do though by doing some
sort of aggregates right like a box and
whiskers plot we can do that by doing
computing these aggregates on our data
set and we only have to return these
summary statistics and that actually
makes it possible to Zoo the plot
without having to do any fancy like pass
SVG's around between machines which
would you know be not a lot of fun so
this this is a really simple plot it's
the like pronouns of the speakers here
or it was it was from a few weeks ago
but yeah and it's it's not merged into
master just yet because of the
refactoring and fixing of all the tests
this one needs to be rebased
but if anyone wants to implement some
graphs on top of sparkling pandas I
would be super happy and and you should
come talk to me and we can talk about
like what sort of steps would be
involved and if you just want to write
the Python side I could do the Scala
side or vice versa whatever more
contributors always welcome please so
I've hinted at some of the things on
this slide a bit so far right what makes
sparkling pandas fast now admittedly
it's for a really really flexible
definition of the word fast at the end
of the day sparkling pandas is slower
than regular spark data frames because
we're keeping track of extra bits of
information and we're also doing some
things which spark avoided doing because
they're kind of slow but we wanted to do
so that we could expose a more friendly
API so if your stuff Maps really well to
just pure spark data frames it might be
a better fit for you but yeah so here's
some of the things that we do to try and
make things really fast
we keep data in the JVM for as long as
possible
I mentioned that PI spark was
implemented using PI for J and part of
that means that when we're doing sort of
operations in PI spark we end up having
to serialize and deserialize a lot of
data repeatedly and it turns out for a
lot of distributed computing stuff your
serialization cost is actually a
significant percentage of your time k
had a really interesting talk on that at
spark summit West
2015 on sort of the things which make
distributed jobs slow another thing that
we do is we're distributed so for some
cases we can be faster than processing
on a local machine that's normally when
your data is actually too big to fit on
your local
oisin if your data is measured in kilo
bytes don't use sparkling pandas it's
it's gonna I mean it'll probably work
but it's not really intended for that
it's intended for like when you have too
much data and you really needed a
distributed system the other one is is
lazy operations and we sort of cheat on
lazy operations but I feel less bad
about this because at the end of the day
so does PI spark
sorry sort of spark data frames
essentially we need to keep track of
some extra schema information and
sometimes the only way to figure out
what's happening with your data is to
evaluate some of it and see what the
schema transformation is because we
can't introspect to your function super
well so sometimes we'll evaluate like
chunks of your data but we use laziness
as much as possible so we only evaluate
a tiny slice of your data to do schema
inference on and the rest of the stuff
is still able to benefit from Sparx
pipelining the final way in which we're
incredibly fast is I drink a lot of
coffee I'm actually double fisting
coffee today and and you can be as
energetic as I am even if you wake up at
six o'clock in the morning if you drink
two cups of coffee sorry
so in our goal to try and support the
the pandas API we we have a bunch of
supported operations most of them are
pretty basic but this sort of gives you
an idea of the kinds of simple
operations that we've implemented
there's a mod there's a bunch more as of
like about 1 a.m. but I was asleep so I
didn't have a chance to update the slide
with the things that got merged in but
you can go and check out our website for
more information
so as I've been trying to trick convince
all of you to contribute to sparkling
pandas this wonderful graph shows that
you are all super convinced and in this
hypothetical wonderful future you're all
joining us
you're helping us write the amazing
interface that is sparkling pandas so
we've done a bunch of work admittedly
the work done graph really hasn't
changed a whole lot since the last time
we gave the talk but that's more out of
laziness with graphs I like to think
we've we've actually progressed a little
bit more than the graph shows to be fair
our hypothetical wonderful future is
maybe somewhat optimistic but there's a
lot of people in the room and you know I
hope you all or at least you know half
of you 10% whatever some of you come and
join us at making sparkling pandas
awesome um so there's a bunch of other
things right you you might not want to
use sparkling pandas and I won't hold it
against you if you go and use blaze
blaze is a really cool project from
continuum which gives you some data
frame like operations and can runs on a
bunch of different backends including
spark so blaze is pretty rad there is a
a de taos distributed data frame I hope
I got their name right and it's actually
been released I believe now and there's
also a number which I haven't played
with but it's it's another option and to
be fair like if you search for
distributed data frame on Google like
you're going to get a bunch of options
any of them could be better than
sparkling pandas honestly I think
sparkling pandas is pretty cool but I am
the one wearing upended ress so take it
with a grain of salt so if you do want
to actually try out sparkling pandas and
and I think that would be awesome we
have our website very fancy dot-com cost
nearly $10 you can check us out at
sparkling pandas calm our codes all on
github so github.com such sparkling
pandas we have a mailing list it's not
super active because despite my optimism
with convincing people to join the
project our last talk didn't really join
our committer base outside of people I
knew in San Francisco so mostly I just
hang out with Juliet and we write the
code together but if anyone wants to
like use the mailing list
that would be rad and we'll totally try
and answer your questions on the mailing
list so most people probably know where
to get pandas from pandas dij org if you
don't have a spark getting spark set up
can be a bit trickier so spark dot
Apache org it can't be PIP installed
right now it just has some a lot of Java
dependencies really but spark toad
Apache org if you are how many people
have an in-house cluster ok cool how
many people run their stuff on like AWS
ok right so so for the people that
either have an in-house cluster or
running their stuff on AWS many of the
vendors like cloud era and and stuff
like that ship version of spark with
their more recent distributions so you
can upgrade your version and if you're
running your stuff on AWS there's
there's some stuff in EMR to
automatically launch a spark cluster and
there's also some scripts in that
directory called spark ec2 to just spin
up a spark cluster and I think it's a
really great way to start experimenting
with both spark and sparkling pandas
cool so I have a really cute red panda
who is eating does anyone have any like
questions about sparkling panda spark I
also have buttons with our very fancy
new logo these buttons are I think they
cost about $10 to make all of the
buttons and they're free today to you
and if you ask a question I'll even run
up and give you a button if anyone wants
to ask a question ok yes
who said that
and I'm up for you cool thank you
does anyone have non button related
questions
we now have you a button expert handling
the button distribution in questions ok
no no non button related questions oh
cool uh sorry yeah sure ok yeah sorry
about that
so RTD is how SPARC represents it's
distributed data it's called a resilient
distributed data set rdd's are really
awesome and and ok I'm jumping up and
down a little bit um but so rdd's are
are these things which are resilient so
that means if a node fails it's okay
you're not going to lose your data
they're distributed so they're on many
machines and it contains data but like
the resiliency is actually achieved in
kind of a neat way what happens with
SPARC is when you're applying these
transformations not only is it like
delaying the evaluation by constructing
this graph of all of the operations that
you're doing it's actually keeping that
graph of operations around in case one
of the nodes failed that had some of
data that you've cached on it from your
computation and then it'll use this
graph to recompute the missing data this
is pretty awesome because you know
recomputing just a small subset of your
data tends to be faster than writing
everything to disk three times after
each single operation which some other
systems have to do does that awesome was
there a second question that was not
button related oh cool do you want to
just shout it out I can't really see
very well the lights
okay sure so um just to repeat the
question to make sure I got it so the
question is when you use sparkling
pandas does it distribute the work on
multiple nodes is that the question cool
awesome yeah it totally does rdd's are
automatically distributed on different
nodes and so are data frames so since
sparkling pandas uses rdd's and data
frames the data and the work is
automatically distributed on different
nodes across your cluster you can sort
of fine-tune things a little more
specifically if you like care about the
number of like workers and partitions
and stuff like that but it's it's done
automatically if you don't specify
anything cool that's a great question so
the question was which parts of the or
how did we decide which parts of the
Python pandas API we implemented first
and which parts we wanted to save for
later so there were two things the first
thing was I looked at the pandas API and
I said to myself Holden what is going to
be easy to implement and honestly that's
where a lot of the stuff started from
but we also like needed to do something
actually useful to people so we needed
to balance doing things that look like
we were making progress with things
which someone could actually use and
that's why we implemented group-by right
because like all of these single
operations on a regular data frame are
really easy to implement when you're not
having to do any sort of grouping or
sorting logic because distributed
systems are really easy to work one
record at a time but we wanted to make
something that someone would want to use
so we decided we'd implement at least
one hard thing that someone would
probably care about and we figured
grouping was probably like a good place
to start
we might do some funky drawing
operations if that stuff people care
about if there's operations that you
really want to see sparkling panda
implement you can either reach out to me
on Twitter or you know oh dear don't
want to you lose our cute panda picture
or you can you can message the mailing
list and or you could even create a
github issue and I would be super happy
more questions yeah that's a good
question so the question is who's using
sparkling pandas and if companies are
are using it to the best of my knowledge
no one's using it in production yet they
probably really shouldn't until about
1:00 a.m. from last night we've had a
bunch of people from different places
get in touch with us and we've mostly
told them to like please wait we we want
to get some changes in so probably our
our next release will email those people
back and let them know that it's like
it's a good time to start using it and
we'll probably do a release in the next
few days so actually yeah that's a good
point um probably don't pip install
sparkling pandas today wait for our next
release but if you want to go and look
at the code like now's a great time to
go and look at the code but maybe not a
good time to install the release package
cool I think you were next
cool sure so the question is essentially
what we're doing around serialization
with the follow-up that you switched
from using Cairo to Java native
serialization and you saw an improvement
nothing or you saw a great improvement
okay that's really interesting um
by default we we use the default
serializer um so this actually means we
we use different serializers for
different things which is kind of funky
for when we're working with rdd's we're
gonna be using sort when we're working
with rdd's of pandas dataframes on the
python side we're using cloud pickle and
in the Java side it's using just the
regular Java serialize ER for like these
these are rays that it's getting passed
when we're doing stuff with data frames
we actually use the the Cairo serialize
er because with the structured data
the Cairo serializer tends to be a lot
better than the regular Java C réaliser
so I would I would really like to chat
with you afterwards maybe about what
your experience was with switching the
too cool and you you had a question -
yeah it's probably gonna explode don't
okay so I'll repeat the question the
question is there's a lot of libraries
that take in pandas dataframes are there
any concerns with passing one of those
libraries a a sparkling pandas dataframe
and the answer is it's not gonna work
fundamentally were we're trying to be as
close as possible to the API but right
now today it's just going to explode if
there's a specific library or or
function in the library that you're
interested
seeing work with it I'd love to talk and
we can look at what would be involved in
making that work okay cool yeah
essentially because it's a distributed
system we still have this explicit
mechanism for like when you need to
bring the data back to the single
machine and like the libraries aren't
going to understand that like certain
operations they'll have to do this thing
to actually poke at the elements but
certain libraries might actually work
provided they just bright purely regular
transformations against the data frame
and it it's kind of a crap shot but I'll
try and make it more awesome oh and I'm
about to get kicked off but if anyone
brought their ham radio to the
conference I'm kilo kilo six Juliet kilo
Quebec I want an excuse to use my ham
radio okay sorry